[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
ومواجهه بين الجيش الاحتلال وفلسطين في
بلده الرام شمال القدس والجيش الاسرائيلي
يعلن التاهب الامني ويعزز من قواته في
القدس وانحاء الضفه الغربيه وفصائل
فلسطينيه تحذر من تزايد تصيد الاسرائيلي
بعد غارات شنها لاحتلال على قطاع غزه في
حين بثت كتائب القسام في غزه صورا لتصدي
الدفاعاتها لطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
اربعوا منظمات المدنيه تجري نقاشا بشان
مبادره لحل الازمه في تونس واتحاد الشغل
يقول ان المبادره ستعرض على الرئيس ويؤكد
ان البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير ومع اقتراب
الدوره الثانيه للانتخابات منظمات واحزاب
تسرح بان المسار اللي انتخابات فاقدون
الشرعيه ويعلق الازمه السياسيه
يرفع المواجهه بين الغربي وروسيا مستوى
جديد وفولندا تقول انها ستسلم ستين دبابه
جديده لاوكرانيا في حين تحدثت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه عن خطه فرنسيه ايطاليه
لامدادك يافا بمنظومه دفاع جوي وبعد 85
عاما من البث مشاعره حزنا وتفاعل واسع على
المنصات العربيه عبر وسم وداعا هنا لندن
مع توقف راديو بي بي سي عربي عن البث
وكانت لاذاعه قد اعلنت سابقا عن قرار
ايقافها وتسريح نحو 400 من موظفيها
لاعتبارات هيكليه الى اللقاء